they are statements of style and
personality craftsmanship and high
fashion we're talking about luxury
watches a market that has boomed
throughout the pandemic total worldwide
sales projected by 2025 52 to 59 billion
dollars and yet these mechanical watches
can cost as little as a couple hundred
bucks mark strassman reports on what
makes this lifestyle market tick
time is money often big money
marquee brand watches like rolex and
omega paddock philippe and panerai the
big hand says style the little one
whispers status or is it the other way
around the watch market in 2022 is going
through a growth spurt unlike we've ever
seen ben climber founded hodinki a
luxury watch website and retailer
roughly 4 million users
its watches new and used start at 50
bucks and end in silly money
climber explained why wearers mostly men
can spend lavishly when smartphones tell
the time for free nobody needs watches
like this is not life or death this
should be fun but what watches do is
they can kind of transport you into a
different version of yourself watches do
more than
tell time they can tell a story they can
speak to you in a very personal way
definitely they speak to celebs like
jay-z and lebron james
ed sheeran i always said like when i
eventually make enough money i will buy
the watch and brook shields for a lot of
people watches or watches for me they're
always
really important pieces of jewelry as an
income flex their watches can cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars apiece
but there's a variety of prices and
styles and undeniably an element of
cosplay throughout astronaut watches
pilot watches dive watches car racing
watches whatever makes you tick and it's
really just a way for people to say hey
this is maybe not who i am but it's who
i could be and in my mind maybe i am
this person when i have this watch on
rockstar john mayer stands front and
center as a celebrity watch collector
anything with this sort of
shale rock stuff that's and an early ho
dinky investor it looks like a bunch of
watches on a table and every single
watch is connected to a person and a
store who can't wait to get it starting
as a kid mayor spent all hours intrigued
by the wizardry of watches i was always
into it i think when you're a kid and
you don't own much the fact that you
could put something on your wrist and it
accompanied you and it was felt like a
tool and felt like you were in some way
or just more equipped you know
and the first nice watch you had rolex
explorer two
couldn't wait
i go to the jeweler in atlanta where we
are
and i had the one moment in my life
where i know they don't take me
seriously because they don't know who i
am you were julia robertson pretty woman
yeah i wanted that a little bit exactly
i wanted it a little bit
i was a lost cause and i had a rolex
before my friends graduated college can
i ask you a question yeah would you take
a picture of my watch in that setup
mayor's passionate about watches with
encyclopedic knowledge
baby's first picture
that's like a glamour shot it's
beautiful we go through a few yeah
absolutely and a collection worth tens
of millions of dollars
but i could also say i took the money
that i made in my 20s
and held on to it a different way and as
investments
watch is more fun than a stock
certificate i'm a musician i'm a misfit
i'm an idiot this does not represent a
complex algorithm that i worked out to
make money i love watches
i did for the last
18 years of the last 20 years blow my
money on watches in the minds of other
people
when apple introduced its watch in 2015
and quickly became the world's best
seller many experts thought time had run
out on luxury watches instead the market
raced even faster it's the gateway drug
frankly for watches you would think that
apple watch 500 bucks multi-functions
yeah
what the hell do you need a fancy watch
for you don't need a fancy watch it
allows you to
appreciate things in a totally different
way and you can call it materialistic
but you can also call it beautiful
for bobby wooten iii a 33-year-old bass
player living in queens new york watches
are an element of style his style i like
colors i like for me it's it's matching
with my outfit and you've got some old
school stuff i do i do this long jeans
1960 right here probably yeah my baby i
guess that's like very nice occasions am
i wearing this one would you ever wear
an apple watch
no i i wouldn't i think because it feels
too robotic for me it feels too like i'm
like conforming to this thing that this
company wants me to like live by
we watched him buy a seiko prospects
monster cost
525 dollars this one has like certain
personnel like these edges and stuff too
yeah for him an expensive watch these
aren't big money i don't do that this is
in john mary's watch collection this is
the watch collection of the guy who's on
stage
just behind john mayer and to the left
playing with them
wooten's typical of something surprising
younger customers millennial and gen z
now drive this market digital
generations with a taste for analog they
put 100 strap on 100 watch and nothing
makes me happier to that they just want
to be part of this community they want
to be part of the club so of all these
washers which one 3940 call it a day in
this community it's all about how a
watch looks
feels makes you feel the barrier to
entry is to love watches all that
matters is you see something that has a
design that speaks to you and that you
want to wear and once you do
it's about time
for cbs saturday morning i'm mark
strassman in atlanta
forget the apple watch i thought this
was the end of watches forever so to
hear that it has not is amazing it's the
watchmaking process too and the skill
involved in putting these together and
also wearing something that doesn't
depend on being charged
you know yeah that's true right
and
there
are
run for that long yeah that's true yeah
well there's 60 watches in my household
so that's all
60.
got to get that watch case well she's
been called the reigning queen of
american comfort food up next on the
dish fried chicken and eggnog waffles
draw fans and celebrities to melba
wilson's harlem restaurant here in new
york we'll take a look
next next week on cbs saturday morning a
new film about kanye west goes back to
his early days before he was a household
name we're going to meet the filmmakers
who spent more than 20 years working on
it
[Applause]
[Music]
60 watches six six mark all mark
no ten or mine
but ten i have ten animals you only wear
that watch i only see you with your
apple yeah i have i have several and a
few have even been stolen my favorite
was my breitling from 2000 and you know
stolen like my children stolen or
actually stolen like like in a hotel
room in los angeles yeah because i know
yeah but i have
a really nice watch which i hope to
hand down to my son someday right is it
that nicole is ready i don't have a
watch on today yeah um
and nicole i think it's the same way
i have to do with victoria she has one
really nice i don't i have my dad's
watch that sort of runs and sort of
doesn't that i i will keep forever and i
used to wear remember those really
chunky michael kors
i have them in gold and silver and rose
gold and like brook shields in that
piece said to me
even when they stopped running it wasn't
that it was just a piece of jewelry and
i've stopped and i have my apple watch
on most of the time that's it well yeah
yeah you kind of i buy a couple extra
bands for it but that's it it's a memory
it's part of who you are then i get it
it's handed down over the years yeah but
then where's my who's counting my steps
i need something i know well my
childhood friend michelle tyson gave
this to me so
it has memories it has a mim yeah so
your apple watch has memories my all of
them have memories
all of them